To access a course,
we'll click on one from this menu.
I'll use Computer Networking
as an example.
Once you're into a course, you'll see
a number of pages over here on the left.
The Dashboard lists all
lessons in the course.
A green check mark will appear when you
have completed all of the videos and
quizzes in a lesson.
The orange playback icon will
appear next to the lesson
you most recently viewed.
Gray circles will appear next to
any lesson you have started but
have not completed.
Or you can download the entire
course's videos and
transcripts over on the right.
For some courses, you'll find
a materials section over on the left.
Here you may find some
course information.
>> Different courses use
these pages differently.
Some courses list their
information on T-Square,
others will list it on Udacity.
Make sure to pay attention
to where the information for
the course you're taking is listed.
But for the vast majority of time
you're working with Udacity.com,
you'll be in the classroom.
So let's take a look at that next.